hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet this is a little clip from
my interview with mike mayer who's a
breathwork coach and we're talking all
about the dangers of being a mouth
breather i actually did an experiment
last year where i taped my mouth shut
for 30 days while sleeping and that is
something i still do to this day because
it helps me sleep better at night it
helps me wake up with a less dry mouth
and so this is a thing that i've
generally taken away from this like
breathwork stuff when i tried it last
year but yeah let's roll the clip but we
talk about the dangers of mouth
breathing so a few months ago i read the
book breath by james nestor or rather
listen to the
and basically every single chapter in
that book talks about how mouth
breathing is like you know
the coming of satan
there's all of these negative effects of
mouth breathing and he kind of talks
about how
mouth breathing is bad for your jawline
mouth breathing is bad for like
basically basically everything
imaginable um
is that is that legit is mouth breathing
like actually killing us as james nestor
would potentially have us believe
you know you you look at the experiment
he did where he bunged his nose up with
two ear plugs for 10 days he looked
really bad at the end of those 10 days i
think very quickly within the first day
or so his blood pressure had gone up x
amount of points
his sleep was impacted and then i think
he said you know something like 30 of
the american population are breathing
like this all the time and then when he
took those earplugs out of his nose him
and anders olsen i've interviewed both
of them actually um when he took those
earplugs out of his nose i get i think
it was within a matter of hours his
blood pressure started to come back down
again and started to feel more himself
so again is it is it that bad if it's a
breathing exercise i would say no go go
and have some fun with the breathing
exercises but the thing is if most of us
are chronically hyperventilating all the
time we need to get that foundation
fixed first before we stop playing with
the sexy stuff with the big breathing
exercises because that's the stuff
that's going to make sure that we're in
a better place because if you take for
example
you know that wim hof breathing which is
30 big breaths in and then a pause that
is known as a stressor it's like going
to the gym you're stressing yourself out
and there's some benefits to that but if
you're already stressed because you've
been mouth breathing
all day i don't think it's the right
thing for you then to go and do some
more hyperventilation i think we need to
do it the other way let's get our
baseline right let's get it secure and
then once it's in a good place we can
then start to play with them okay
so um
let's say someone someone watching or
listening to this is like all right cool
i'm sold i want to do this nose
breathing rather than mouth breathing
thing are there any
are there any tangible benefits they
would get within a reasonable amount of
time or is it like i don't know taking
supplements where it's like oh i know i
probably should do this just so my body
is b12 levels or a baseline but i'm not
really going to notice
a real difference yeah yeah well by the
way i feel like that about turmeric i've
been taking tumor for two years although
what am i doing here with this bloody
tune brick um so so i i was a chronic
mouth breather and there are some
measurements that you can do so one of
them is um uh well patrick mcewen the
author of the oxygen advantage calls
maximum uh breathlessness test so what
that is that is you because it's always
good to measure isn't it you wanna be
able to measure and track your things
and so what you do is you do a normal
breath in normal breath out your cap and
then you walk um and you count the steps
you can walk and you make a note of that
and another one is you do a breath in
breath out hold and you wait till the
first impulse to breathe happens and
that gives you two numbers so you can
start to track that but let's talk about
what are some of the benefits um and i
think it's about flipping on its head
sometimes so what are the problems
because
here's the thing you know i um i like a
bit of grounding i saw a documentary
about ground and how important it is
that our body touches the earth and this
is a whole other conversation you know
we're the first animal that's removed
our body from the planet which is really
bad you know put insulation on our shoes
and actually you can measure the the
kind of um
electromagnetic static in your body uh
when you touch the earth it kind of
falls down and blood moves better it's a
wonderful documentary
but we're these people that that
kind of expect a big benefit but
actually a lot of us bringing us back to
baseline to be not to be that chimpanzee
with a can of coke with a poor posture
it's more about let's just get us to how
nature intended us to be as opposed to
oh there's loads and loads i'm going to
feel like i'm superman well you might
get some of that but if you're a really
poor breather you might not even know
what good breathing feels like until you
do it i drive people mad because when
i'm breathing when i'm talking i'll i'll
take a normal breath in through the nose
now to carry on the conversation um
because i want to keep that kind of good
habits going so some benefits then so
let's let's break some of this down so
um there are some breathing exercises
that can improve your heart rate
variability and some studies on that so
there's one breathing exercise called
coherence breathing
and that heart rate variability is the
the gap between the beats and they say
that the kind of the variability of
those beats kind of signifies like good
health
sleep is a huge one so probably my
favorite benefit of good breathing i
know you've done mouth taping um and
if you are mouth breathing in the night
which so many of us are because remember
if we're mouth breathing in the gym and
mouth breathing while we're recording
videos and all that sort of stuff and we
talk all day we might be talking all day
and doing different things then there's
a good chance that you might be going to
mouth at some point in the night
now what does that what's the problem
with that well you're never going to get
into the deeper levels of sleep if
you're a mouth breather
and then we know then that poor sleep is
associated with an increased risk of
diabetes cancers high blood pressure um
you know i uh before i mouth taped i was
a frequent weir in the night and i just
thought that was normal and then the
minute i started the matter is i'm not
going for wee anymore i'm like what's
going on there and it's because our body
is releasing the right amount of kind of
hormones and suppressing the feelings of
going to the toilet and that sort of
thing and you get a better night's sleep
and be interesting to know your thoughts
on how you experience it because for me
it took me a couple of months it was so
bloody unnatural to have something on my
mouth i would rip it off but i
persisted with it and now my sleep is is
better i wake up more refreshed i don't
have a dry mouth and so sleep you know
in itself if i just said look i've got
this magical pill for you here that's
going to help you sleep better and it's
going to reduce all the risks associated
with sleep or how much does that pill
i'd love to take that and it might be
able to improve your heart rate
variability and it's gonna be able to
lower your blood pressure um and uh
we've not gone to diaphragm yet but
diaphragmatic breathing could help with
lower back issues could help with
digestive issues so there's a whole host
of other mechanical issues which we can
get into
because our diaphragm's not moving
properly as well and again we want to be
a functional efficient breather
okay so plenty of benefits of
nose breathing and i yeah i mean i still
take my mouth
to uh to this day i don't do it on days
like if for example i'm staying over at
my mom's place and i forget to take my
3m surgical tape then i'm like oh okay
cool i guess i'm not mouth taping
tonight but i do find that on days i
don't know i don't know if this like i i
need to actually track the data on this
properly but
i do find that on days where i have
taped my mouth properly and wake up
having not ripped it off i just feel
like it's it's a bit of fat take it off
and like get in the way of like mustache
and beard and stuff yeah once i've done
that i feel like oh i'm actually i
actually feel pretty rested tonight hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day